lol team rot wird der release von block
ins bett wurden zerstört
alter wie schnell geht das denn der eine
typ macht es da gerade im alleingang
leute was geht ab hier ist euer granie
und heute gibt es eine runde matt ward
allerdings seht ihr vielleicht dass ich
gerade bei meinem bruder was auch leider
bei sk und die sagt edwards normalen
grippe die leute bei bedways neigen
immer dazu dass sie ein bisschen scheiß
machen wenn youtube in der runde sind
hier unten ist das bett das müssen wir
beschützen hier sparen so versuchen die
sachen die wir kriegen oder es nicht
kriegen weil der andere typ die alle
kriegten ganze zeit mit denen können wir
uns sachen kaufen bei irgendwelchen
quelle gemerkt auch zum ersten mal ist
es sind vier gegen vier
deshalb geht es noch relativ schnell
schätze ich mal einer bot sich schon
direkt über das sind zwei tyrannosaurus
rex findet nichts als richtig erkennen
und es scheint relativ flott hier zur
sache zu gehen
bei den modus ich weiß nicht wo sind die
billiger hier auf dieser karte bei dem
anwalt die man handeln kann
einer da drüben hat auf jeden fall schon
sachen gehabt komisch ich kann mich ja
schon vier blöcke wurden damit werde ich
direkt den ersten schritt machen
jemand aus dem gegnerischen gegnerische
team fragten die auf den screen machen
können also auch für gut ich bin gut
schreiben die konnte sie gut
na ja es hat auf jeden fall probleme ihr
euch wahrscheinlich denken könnt wenn
ihr gerade mich hier sprechen hört und
seht damit dass er videos hochladen
können liegt daran dass er dass er im
moment dass sein laptop irgendwie forum
spinnt also der laptop macht irgendwie
nicht so das wasser soll zum beispiel
also er hat einfach eigentlich diese
krassen die krassen raindrops ich bin
der volksvertretung leid klasse frame
drops meine haare sehen so schwebt
wahrscheinlich kein fonds treffen kann
es hat mich auch er kann nicht mal
anständig zocken und von aufnahmen sind
natürlich ganz zu schweigen
an mir dran
sie kommt schon unsere gegner natürlich
dankeschön schon mal alle leute die sich
mir in den weg gestellt haben beim beim
sachen wollen nicht sehr sozial kann ich
screen spiel normal man jemand anderes
schreibt halt die klappe sagt auch bei
ihm definitiv
ich brauche es noch ein gold wann kommt
noch ein gold hat der bot schon ein das
ist gutes gutes gutes gut
am besten ist es wenn man es mit kisten
einbaut weinkisten kann man nicht so
schnell abbauen
es gibt ja spitzhacken ja aber es gibt
auch haken aber es gibt keine echse mit
dem man jetzt irgendwie gästen relativ
flott abbauen könnte deshalb ist immer
so ein ganz guter tipp was man machen
kann wenn man sich halt ein bisschen
verteidigen werden
aber ich glaube die runde könnte was
werden ich hoffe dass wir jetzt relativ
schnell zu fassen
wenn wir es relativ schnell durchkommen
zu den gegnern
denn was drin auf jeden fall offen wir
oft mit den leuten immer ein paar sachen
abgeben
die schwierigkeiten die man sehr viele
leute haben dass sie einfach
wer dass sie einfach nicht richtig nicht
das spiel von sie verstehen weil man
spielt ja zusammen und läutet der ries
vom blog das bett wurden zerstört
erst dadurch schon raus jetzt vorüber
und guckt dass wir noch ein paar kills
rege alter wie schnell geht das denn der
eigenbetrieb macht sich da gerade im
alleingang ein letzter tipp lebt noch
alte jiji das war die schnellste und
aller zeiten
ich dachte einer wird noch leben weiß
kilo eclipse auch die alte schädel sind
ja auch immer dass wir leute nicht
gewinnen können dann schreiben kilowatt
wir gucken auch wir noch schneller und
nein kommt vielleicht ist aber etwas
anders wir schon vorbei aber auch wieder
so ein ding zwei gegen zwei
keine andere stadt das ist los geht's
was könnte ich mal erzählen also mein
bruder ist ja bald wieder hier bei mir
mein freund verraten bewohner recht
unkonzentriert
also ist auf jeden fall bald wieder
zurück zu hause dann können wir wieder
ein bisschen was zusammen aufnehmen so
ein patient einen kanal vielleicht
wieder ein bisschen leiden lassen
das muss ich mir noch tausender mehr in
die haare fast alles so schrecklich leid
ein kurzer katja kipping hat nicht
vergessen
durch gratis zu unserer reinigungs hilfe
gesagt wenn ich mir auch mal ein
bisschen schlaf kriege ich jetzt
das einfach hier zwei shop mehr gibt auf
jeden fall einige hin was mache ich denn
der ist krankhafte angeklagt kräfte
stimmt zum kicker hallo leute schlagen
sie hier um diese basic sachen das ist
sonst nie so ansonsten ist immer so dass
die ganzen leute mit zehn abos oder doch
zwei autos habe ich mittlerweile glaube
ich ganz sicher was natürlich klar dass
mich leute nicht kennen bestimmt auch
irgendwelchen leuten da draußen noch die
ungeschnittene kennen
aber das ist natürlich ein finger
abzählen
gibt jemand so darum dass man unter den
anderen runter kommt noch nicht konkret
aber auch gut wenn man mal nicht erkannt
wird weil die leute spielen oft wirklich
nicht so wie das vom erfinder gedacht
ist das spiel das halte ich immer ein
bisschen ärgerlich wenn die seiten
glücklich fehlen
denn er halt irgendwie leute mir alles
geben und sich selbst mit skaten oder so
heißt es war gut für mich aber für sie
ist wirklich scheiße
deshalb danke
dann kann ich lächerlich zu starten
was zu fressen auf jeden fall hat man
nie mangel an diesem ganzen basics aber
jetzt gerade ist es wirklich ein
bisschen kraft früher wieder hoch und
schauen was die anderen leute so machen
auf jeden fall ziemlich blass ist ein
ganz neuer spielmodus den habe ich jetzt
ein paar tage ein bisschen angetastet
und wie gesagt bin ziemlich zufrieden
damit sind denn ganz geil
also ich hoffe mal dass noch keiner von
denen bogen hat sonst bin ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich direkt tot aber ich habe
schon mal ein schwert und natürlich ganz
so schlecht dass vielleicht schaffen wir
ja mal selbst in schwerte
eisenachs
ok wird hier oben drüber
und jetzt werde ich am montag hilft
meistens gerade so dimon
was macht er
wir müssen uns kraft beeilen wenn der
antrieb darum jetzt direkt ankommt dann
effekten fest problem
wir sind auf guten derzeit ja nie
gedacht dass man zwei bis unten oder
unterbringen kann in einer aufnahme aber
schade also ich brauche jetzt einfach
gutes equipment oder irgendjemand
bräuchte man dann können wir durch
steppen so lange hat noch niemand so
richtig op sachen hat ich gehe jetzt
wieder hoch man das nur durch
so kommt schon beim stopfen rede war von
uns das schon gut fand wahrscheinlich
als klar als gleis ksk wer baut denn
diese teile
nach alter das war das war gut das habe
ich nämlich ich hab nichts nichts gehabt
also für mich ist komplett und
problematisch ich gestorben bin und er
hat auf jeden fall auf jeden fall
behindert meine freunde
nein nein
der erste von den datenbogen jetzt ist
das spiel ziemlich in balance
40 kilo und hey nummer ja das ist das
ist jetzt scheiße weil jetzt hat einer
von denen buch ich davon unser noch
niemanden bogen und jetzt haben sie
nicht schon zu publikum an
weil wobei hinein sind natürlich nicht
gewonnen weil wir können ja jetzt nicht
plötzlich zu uns kommen und musik oder
so allerdings ist es schon ganz schöner
vorteil wenn ein bogen art vollen man
kennt hier direkt über im untergrund und
damit man einfach einmal rund tag
geschubst und zwar sogar zwei im bogen
content weißt was ich freue mich jetzt
einfach unten entlang
vielleicht klappt's ja aber ich habe gar
keine blöcke
wir spielen ein bisschen 100 meine leute
bin ich ja immer darauf gibt die anderen
fahren weil die ganze zeit zusammen und
machen nicht so wirklich die action die
kurve kriegen auch alles irgendwie jetzt
auch noch formsache
wie gut der anführer zu kommen das tue
ich nicht gut das klingt nicht gut
okay okay jetzt kommt so anderen von
afag komm schon
ich muss dir erschwerte tropfen dieser
ganzen insel
okay mein base betritt zerstört wir sind
jetzt so gut wie am arsch weil so wenn
ich jetzt noch ein einziges mal sterne
sind wir draußen aber dann wisst ihr wie
das funktioniert das geht halt immer
darum geht immer darum diese stützpunkte
von den anderen zu zerstören
ich werde einfach einen bogen und dann
noch mal irgendwie mein glück probieren
sie außen möchte ein gold okay ich bin
nach egal dann seht ihr auch mal wie das
ist wenn man musik gespielt
ich denke mal dass nicht allzu viele
leute immer so und noch land ist auf
jeden fall gut spielen ich denke mal
dass demnächst oder ich hoffe dass die
nicht mein bruder irgendwann auch wieder
videos machen kann
und ja das alter
das ging ja
wenn ich hier auch so schnell
super schnäppchen oder ich möchte auf
jeden fall viel spaß mit dem wie bist
mein bruder wenn wieder welche kommt und
bis dann